[Music]
okay let's get you ready to fight wait
what well multi-platform global
operation every fight live stream on the
dark web thousands of viewers placing
beds as we speak this is going to take
your brand to a whole new level i think
there's been some sort of confusion i
like your spike face they're my guesses
usually you gotta fight your way to
central ring but viral style like you
found a line baby i'm not here to bite
anybody okay i'm looking for my sister
never heard of her we just lost a fight
at the last minute so you get the next
slot
[Applause]
nice one helen
is he anybody in one of these oh no no
no no these are like low level fights
you're gonna be fighting
up there
[Music]
throughout my life
the ten rings gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family
you are your mother
and whether you like it or not
you are also your father
i told my men
they wouldn't be able to kill you if
they tried
glad i was right
here's just a criminal
who murders people
be careful
i thought i could change my name
start a new life
but i could never
escape his shadow
my son
you can't run from your past
[Applause]
is this what you wanted
you got this
thank you
[Music]
you